if we give a thousand subs on this
episode Sam will come back as the skin
Lord in the next episode I got it okay I
want to hear the two notes just give
them two notes just give them how do
they know what they're gonna buy it
separately but not together all right
series separately I don't know how to do
that I'm one word no if we change the
sample dude if we change the subject
I bet the skin Lord promises in real
life I even told Casey and Clinton like
I'm never gonna tell you how I did
golden spoon or in a cold stone you walk
in there you can ask for a sample before
you buy Wow what a week we've had guys
we're going to Austin Texas next week
I'll tell y'all about that and this week
a lot of things are happening a lot of
things have happened this week we've got
an article 13 passes and the EU we've
got a crazy situation with this Jesse
small a thing we've got copycat prim
tech channels and and much much more so
wow what you guys want to start with 13
okay 13 he goes been on this one
let me just tell ya the EU passed on
Tuesday the article the the the school
art of the legislation
yeah the legislation that includes
article 13 which so it's not law yet
basically it has to go to the European
Council and then the European Council
needs to approve it which they said they
will and then it takes two years to
implement so basically in two years this
is going to be EU law now now what is it
it's been opposed by tech companies
because it says that it requires them to
build really expensive content filters
and stop linking publications and
to come up with all these different
deals with content companies well what
is it though so what is it yeah so what
does it say
that's a good question yes so if you
don't know article 13 is the European
legislation that basically requires
content companies such as Google
Facebook to provide either come to
agreements with with traditional media
companies or to come up with better
measures that keep their stuff off of
platforms basically to prevent copyright
infringement to bring copyright law into
the 21st 7-10 even even bigger picture
babies version the European version of
the DMCA yes exactly
big picture is they're trying to stop
copyright infringement and so this is
the latest measure in doing so but what
it does is it usually from what I
believe it put is it is putting the
blame on the provider or the host of the
content rather than the user who was
infringing yes so that's the core that I
was that I was struggling to get to
thank you Sam cuz I I did not get there
but that's basically yeah it it puts
liability on the host so if you're a
youtube user
you upload copyright infringing content
onto YouTube the this provision is now
saying that YouTube should in part be
liable for that to the owner of the
copyright yeah so you say so that so
Nico's got some good insights on this I
think you should take take this from
here and they go yeah well I think it's
worth quickly touching upon before we
get too deep in that stuff that there's
a lot of talk around article 13 and a
lot it's like it's been a great
opportunity for journalists to scare
everybody so what does to sharpen their
teeth in taxes means are gonna be banned
eat you bad you bad nothing 13 is good
or bad by the way I'm just pointing out
that there's a lot I mean we have a
headline pulled over here we'll get to
the goods and Bad's yeah Europe just
passed a sweeping new copyright rule
case would be kick let's let's roll this
carpet slowly yeah so I think the very
first thing to do to do here is we got
our own very own lawyer sitting in the
seat right next to me woo we got the
wording of the law itself so you guys
let's all be informed let's not just
take journalists swords for it let's not
just read memes and they assume that's
what tells us what it is let's read the
article itself I get my news from memes
thank you alright I get my news from
reddit comments thank you very much so
[Music]
we have the actual the actual article
here there's two parts one is the text
proposed by the Commission and one is an
amendment and being not entirely
familiar with EU law I'm not exactly
sure which one gets prevented presented
to the European Council so I'll just
give you a summary of the total of
because most of its most of it's the
same there's only like slight
differentiations in language but
basically it says this information
society service providers that store and
provide to the public access of large
amounts of works on other subject manner
uploaded by their users aka YouTube
Google shall in cooperation with rights
holders take measures to ensure the
functioning of agreements concluded with
the rights holders for the use of their
works on the platforms effectively so
saying you YouTube and Facebook need to
come to agreements with rights holders
on the use of those works on their
platforms that's all it says for the for
the first part of it now later it says
those measures such as the use of
effective content recognition
technologies shall be appropriate and
proportional the service providers shall
provide rights holders with adequate
information on the functioning and
deployment of those measures as well
when relevant adequate reporting on the
recognition and use of the works and
other subject matters so they'll they'll
give
data basically on how the how the
algorithms and the Content ID systems
are functioning as well as how much
you're stuck work my than shared right
and then beyond that it says that if
people don't want their stuff they on
the platforms then they need to make
sure they have provisions to prevent
stuff from being published on the
platforms and they also need to provide
basically means of arbitration to those
to those what is the word they used to
dress no well yeah to redress to redress
grievances yeah but to the to the
content owners mm-hm
so is that it that's it that's it that's
what it says Wow yeah that's that's
basically it like there's some other
like little bits and bobs of verbage but
ultimately like the core of it that's
that's what it is and that's what it
says so the big complaint was that it's
too broad but it's pretty it's very
broad but at the same time all it's
saying is hey you guys should probably
come to agreements with rights holders
for people uploading copyright
infringing content so the question is
like is it time for YouTube and Google
and the Facebook's of the world to
finally step up and say okay as the
hosts of this content should we should
we should we finally be liable for this
I think just I just want to briefly
right before I answer that question and
we jump into that someone point out like
my initial reaction to you reading that
is it sounds pretty reasonable I'm not
gonna lie like maybe you can get
interpreted interpreted in a bunch of
different ways it can get interpreted in
a bunch of negative ways but to me it
sounds kind of identical to what we
already have in America which is
copyright holders need a way to get
their work pulled off of a site if they
want it pulled off of a site
hence the DCMA takedown and decides need
to have a function in place to do so it
seems completely reasonable
whether I mean people have come up with
horror stories but how now this means
that everybody needs like pay a fee if
they're gonna upload anything to YouTube
and Nene they like you know everything's
gonna be closed and memes will be banned
like I'm not seeing any of that you know
I don't see the meme thing well you're
gonna upload copyright infringement and
now but like maybe there's more to it
than what was there but we missing
something guys I feel like we're missing
something this is from the official
European Parliament website right that
is it articles you read articles that's
it yes I just summarized it when I'm not
gonna sit here for an hour and read like
okay there's like more stuff about how
to go about this okay let me go through
this all right well you know I can talk
well yeah let me read it because this
kind of drives this conversation to a
halt if that's it I mean I'm gonna tell
a story well Jake reads this so remember
when Facebook was like goin real hard on
Facebook video and like they start
auto-playing videos and just like yeah
you know you can see the the numbers
just ballooning up there yeah
people are going hard stealing our
content and reuploading it to their to
their Facebook pages because you know
Facebook was blocking youtube links
people would rip our videos off YouTube
and just upload it on Facebook video and
they would cut out all our you know
watermarks that cut our end card so
clearly it was a intentional it wasn't
just like oh this is a cool video I'll
share it as an intentional I'm going to
take this video clip off all their stuff
and promote myself with it and that was
pretty frustrating now we would go
through the women we still do this all
the time it would go through the
Facebook copyright you know things get
taken down but of course in this process
Facebook is making money off the ads
playing against our videos and you know
they'd eventually take it down and ask
them - but they'd keep all that ad
revenue that they made from our content
and our content over and over and
overand and millions and millions of
views I'm not talking like 2 or 3
million target millions 50 million ah
yeah I'd say we we've lost anywhere
between 25 to 75 thousand dollars from
copyright infringement on Facebook yeah
in Adsense so Facebook just gets to keep
that money and they're not punished when
it happens again and again and again
like when we we pull the same video 15
times Facebook that like you're like
okay you know we could try to take them
to small claims court or some BS like
that of course you know that's not worth
it or gonna lead to anything right um
and so the part of me that went through
that experience is like
oh wait Facebook itself will be liable
for hosting our copyrighted material and
not just the users that did it but like
the site that's enabling it and not
really taking any steps to stop it
probably's like heck yeah yeah so that's
like you know the Internet is it is it
to a point of maturity now where the
distribution mediums that have been
fostered since the dawn of what was that
site the original music sharing site one
where no before LimeWire Napster Napster
since the dawn of Napster when basically
the music industry fell apart in a
period of three years in the early 2000s
is it has that come to a point of
maturity where it's time to consider
these not as like bastardized
second-rate distribution mediums but as
the the distribution mediums of the
future which they ultimately and
realistically are and to treat them
accordingly I mean I think when you have
companies are worth billions and
billions of dollars building their
entire infrastructure off of the content
of its users the company being required
to not just get away scot-free off that
content that they didn't create but you
know making out of it with billions of
dollars it seems like there might be
need to be a rule in place for that but
when I have initially heard about
article 13 what it sounded like to me
was just somebody trying to apply old
laws to new art which is a very
different thing you know the Internet
has democratized art is democratized
filmmaking music yeah all that kind of
stuff and this sounded like it was going
to stop all that and try to clamp it
back down so that only big media
companies had control over it again
yeah you know here's I'm trying to find
like an analogy that makes sense to me
because like I go through I've gone
through couple here like to try and put
this into perspective one is imagine you
have a big house or a big room and you
allow anyone to go into this room anyone
I've made this big warehouse anyone can
go into it right and before long people
start going into your warehouse
committing crimes people reporting the
crimes you're like sorry right sorry I
mean like how I come here house I'm not
I said anyone can come in here I'm not
gonna like control or like mouse yeah
I'll say I'll put a rules list up on the
wall
maybe I'll kick people out occasionally
but yet the cops are still getting
dozens of reports that people are
getting like molested and beat up in
this room and I'm still sitting here
going like whatever man you know it's
like I posted the rules you know you be
your own in jail so yeah but your place
will get shut down yeah you know and so
this is kind of like the digital version
of that where you have an open free
space where anyone can come in now
then that analogy is like kind of works
but it kind of doesn't because we're
talking about physical things here we're
not we're not talking about ideas which
are super subjective and you know that
it's just a completely different realm
entirely you know and and so I don't
know I mean this does make accommodation
for existing copyright law and existing
like it's it's not saying that this now
takes authority over fair use and things
like that it's saying like just fair use
an American law by the way right but
it's there's there's versions of it in
Europe so this is all like kind of like
an administrative nonsense the main the
main portion of it is right here there's
another I'll just read it a read another
section from the amendment side
licensing agreements which are concluded
by online content sharing service
providers with rights holders shall
cover the liability for works uploaded
by the users of such online content yeah
so yeah you know they're saying the
hosts are liable for the copyright
infringing yeah yeah and you know what
and I think I completely
that the more I think about it these we
look at these companies like Facebook
and Google and they're making billions
of dollars they've CEOs that are making
millions and millions and flying and
they got the private jets and planes and
yachts and stuff like that and without
their user base they would not have a
single dollar and those companies
control Facebook and Google control but
eighty-five percent of all digital had
money yeah you know their their take so
it's not like they're it's not like we
can't do this because it's going to
stifle new up-and-coming business those
businesses are now to a point of
maturity yeah you know so it's basically
doubling down on the existing laws
really that's it's not like a new idea
and necessarily it's just saying hey
remember copyright in that concept well
like we mean it this time
yeah and there is this there is this
instinct in tech specifically that they
that they shouldn't be treated like
everyone else and and it's it's it's
it's a double-edged sword like minoo it
sometimes it benefits us sometimes it
benefits others sometimes it hurts us
sometimes it hurts others but the point
is like there is a there is a philosophy
in all these tech companies where it's
like well why do we need to be treated
that way but at the same time
Nicko last week we were talking about
uber and you were saying how well maybe
they shouldn't look at uber like at
reddit transportation company maybe they
need to look at them like an entirely
new thing yeah so you know that's that's
also worthy to note here yeah it's yeah
it's right yeah trying to turn always
like shoehorn a new technology into old
rules it doesn't really get you very far
yeah like calling a company a tech
company it's just like okay like like
right what is that you what does that
even mean anymore like there's
technology in everything around me
except my clothes and this mug well
there's no technology in your clothes to
like water is this scent the way that
was created he was made well this is
actually like a this is like a that is a
bad example because this is surplus like
this money for example they had to use a
computer at some point maybe they had
like Excel and they made their own
custom spreadsheet to figure out how to
attract you inventory so they're kind of
a tech company I mean honestly the
definition of technologies applied like
or yet technology it was it like if
something like applied education into
like creating efficiency for better
production of goods Jerry can you look
up the definition of technology
technology let's open it
techno sort earlier and like the whole
saying of a double-edged sword the
metaphor implies that you hits with your
sword and then it bounces back and hits
you exactly but it cuts your enemies
both ways it doesn't cut you both you
and it cuts me too it's like no it just
means I can get guys on both sides of me
sword Mina can make him benefit you but
it hurts he's making it your handling of
the sword means you hit somebody then it
bounces back and hits you technology
it's from Greek tech art and craft and
logic meaning system right here at ik
the application of scientific knowledge
for practical purposes especially in
industry oh that's what a good
definition yeah I was pretty close
application of scientific knowledge for
practical purposes okay so really a
sentence energy is every company so a
technology though then should probably
be be classified by the practical
purpose for which that's the knowledge
is applied hmm not by the scientific
knowledge itself
ah which is what my argument was for
uber is that let's judge them by the
industry in which they operate not
social media companies I mean
technically you could call uber a social
media company well yeah but it's not
users you they're not they're not
creating and uploading media I guess so
you know and Facebook is a thing where
people create and upload media whether
it's as views
single word or a photo or a video
YouTube is just videos Twitter it is
ideas and text but once again it's me
media comes is is basically the though
it's like it's making ideas tangible
that's what media is basically right
yeah it's it's yeah it's making an idea
literal literal audio or visual or
whatever it literally refers to the
medium upon what you're presenting the
idea yeah
media so so yeah I mean do you guys see
article 13 is hurting quote-unquote the
little guy could how have your meme gets
banned well I mean if let's see so like
let's say we make a we make a video
right and and we're know let's let's
just say like someone and some random
state starts YouTube channel they they
make something and for some reason it
gets copied copy written right or it has
the potential to but then what if
someone else what if someone else like a
bigger company right takes that and it's
like oh we like that we're gonna take
that and they profit off of it and
they're so small their YouTube presence
is so tiny that it's insignificant and
they're totally cheated out and it's
like this bigger company took this idea
that they came up with and we're totally
it took the idea that a little guy to
came up with yes but when that when this
kagura protection benefit that little
guy so does a little guy have a voice
I'm like hey I made this thing and
they're in Google or Facebook is
profiting off of this right now and like
what I make videos in my basement
I feel like this well technically I mean
they might miss that because what this
is advocating for is licensing
agreements between rights holders and
that cotton in the distribution
companies so for example if you're if
you're a SoundCloud artist and you're
just soundcloud artist little SoundCloud
or little cloud then you're probably not
signed with a record label or a rights
distribution company but you know if you
say you're distributing your content
through
district kid or any other the online
distribution companies and as part of
that Google makes an agreement with
distro kid and since you distribute
through them you're okay you can protect
your rights through them because now
they've signed an agreement but if
you're 100% independent somehow I don't
know there's a lot of there's a lot of
ambiguity which is what is what a lot of
the the the opposite opinion of what
we're what we're sort of presenting here
is saying is that is is exactly what
you're saying Clint so it could do that
I I'd be more concerned that that if you
if you created something but I guess
people are already ripping off people
you know so like if if a big company
rips off a little guy that's sort of
already happening so I I don't know I
yeah I don't know if that's aI don't
know if that's necessarily the the main
the main concern that I would have with
it but yeah I mean I mean I think
fundamentally though at a basic level
it's like when you are dealing with the
concept of media in this in this realm
you need flexibility to repurpose and
recycle ideas and content and remix
stuff and evolve it and grow it parodies
and is you know it's like I once again
this law is we're still figuring out the
ambiguity is here with what it actually
entails but ultimately I think it's just
a moral stance it's like when you're
dealing with copyright you want to make
sure that you do have your provisions a
lot of things to expire allow that
wiggle room whether it's fair use or etc
etc like however it can be legally
repurposed still because the moment you
start clamping it down too much and
actually like trying to control these
ideas and like you know then then I
think you're doing humanity a pretty
pretty big disservice so yeah if they
start actually going if it does get to
that level where like the memes you know
that we all care about you know can't be
uploaded and are being banned then I
would and I have to say yes this is bad
but
unfortunately right now I don't actually
I don't see that a sense of that
happening at the moment it seems like
it's really just doubling down on the
laws that are currently existing yeah
it's just is what I my interpretation of
what I've seen of the law itself is
basicly saying sites that host
user-generated content you do have in
place a way for people who happen to
have own a copyright first thing that
was uploaded
illicitly they need to have a system in
place for those people who own that
copyright or that license to have that
content removed and could be one or the
or profit or profit of it so in other
words exactly what's already on YouTube
under the DMCA yeah yeah except for
American law this is European law but I
don't think you can let's say a video
gets to take a million views with ads on
it and I own the copyright to it I don't
get the money they made you don't get
the mind made but you go claiming from
there after though you can cut it from
there after exactly yeah yeah you can
get the app yeah but seeing that I think
that's that's kind of what this is
address this does have provisions for I
mean it does stay in it to like you know
as possible it like there's a lot of
like disclaimer saying as is reasonable
as is possible as is proportional like
her yeah but thankfully they keep really
good records of who gets what you know
so yeah money's already paid out and we
can't just go and get it back I mean
obviously but that takes 16 to 90 days
sure question so ladies let's say we
make a video we upload it we own
copyright to that and yes yeah you can
buy it just by the fact that crania are
loaded it
no not even uploading it just creating
it gives the copyright yeah work as soon
as you create something that has a
modicum of creativity you own the
copyright to whatever you just created
so you can take someone to court based
off of like I did this first yes you
have to prove that you did it first
yes whether it be through an upload or
through a letter that was sent on
yourself the example we always used in
law school was the grade the next great
American novel that was shoved in
someone's top dresser drawer and never
came out and it was like that was always
the question is however you it always
came down to whether or not you could
prove what you're saying but yes as soon
as you as soon as you manifest an idea
into an tangible medium of expression
it has a modicum of creativity you've
created something that's copyrightable
mm-hmm
so they talk about putting a button on
Facebook that says this video was mine
I'm gonna claim this also I'm gonna
claim that I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
take action on this and request the
money that you yes you can already do
this on YouTube because the DMCA
basically they wanted to set up a system
to be in keeping with the DMCA and this
is we're already doing this actually
there's a lot of YouTube videos that are
on there that are are videos that have
been reloaded that we're claiming the
money on yeah and for example Warner
Brothers music is doing that with our
darsana video whether that's right or
wrong they're doing it because of
because of that video because a Star
Wars soundtrack copy written no that
don't do that didn't that that part that
that's F yeah that's pretty close though
yeah they should become sure they get
the whole of it that's like saying my
phone rings in this video and that Apple
claims the ads I think though what say
yeah I would say for aggressive
copyright protection needs to be exactly
matched by aggressive copyright
expiration like if you're gonna
aggressively protect copyrights you all
seem to aggressively pursue things
becoming public domain on the undone
like Mickey Mouse yeah you can't you
can't go out there back no one gets any
of this copyrighted work forever no I
need to be like and he's playing a
patent where it's like no one gets to
use this within the 20 years everyone
can use it
yeah you know Sears for a little while
profit off it run your business and then
it's the cultures but but it's not like
that because basically my son after I am
dead and he is like 60 years old he's
still gonna be making money off of our
YouTube video yeah it's the life of the
author plus I think like seven 75 years
yes it's not crazy
isn't that crazy to think of that and
you're like 2100 okay 2100 might my
aging feeble son is gonna be making
money off of the glitch well he will be
yeah that's pursuing you
it's almost a little it's a little
ridiculous it's kind of ridiculous kind
of ridiculous but yeah it's like go out
and make your own you tell me that's
it's still relevant in the year 2100 the
glitch I mean it's still like a thing
that like people are like you never know
who knows maybe all it's the apocalypse
and they run out of videos to make any
videos in that like you know Star Wars
Star Wars is huge Star Wars is a part of
everybody's culture growing up like in
America
there's very few people that haven't
seen Star Wars everybody loves
lightsabers every loves rebels like you
know Star Wars Nico says Star Wars sucks
oh great the original Star Wars is
awesome it's become a little bit of like
virtuous signaling for nerds but anyways
Star Wars - Tom that's who that was a
Star Wars is a part of our like our
culture at this point and arguably it
should become truly a part of our
culture just like Santa Claus isn't
copyrightable at a certain point
Star Wars needs to become Santa Claus
and I think that point should have
already passed I'd be pissed though if I
came up with Star Wars and I was like
you've already made billions so billions
here you've made your money off it at
this point it's like hey who's mean like
you made way too much money here's the
thing we're gonna cut you off is that
left side of the Democratic Party says
that just I don't worry about I mean are
you think it's it's it would it's right
for all the guys over in in Greece
present modern-day Greece to like like
be ticked off that like people are
printing these free copies of Homer's
Odyssey you know they're like my
great-great-great great-great-great
great-great-great great-great
great-granddaddy wrote this hmm and this
is BS 75 right to do this with a
photograph at Harvard last week what did
she sued Harvard because of apparently a
Harvard scientist took a photograph of
her great-great-great grandfather who
was a slave in South Carolina and she in
this tradition and her family had been
passed down
about how her her great-great-great
great-grandfather and his daughter took
these photos from a Harvard scientist
and eventually came to this woman and
this woman is now suing Harvard for the
photos as well as for the recognition
that that man is her ancestor
even though photo copyright law in the
United States is life of the author plus
25 years or like 70 years from the date
of creation or something like that so
the copyrights way past so so how was
their case again because she filed one
in court she folks even though a lot of
motion for summary judgments gonna
dismiss it yeah it was still a big news
article last week about how this whole
thing we didn't talk about it but it's
funny anyway is kind of a lost cause
basically for her it it should be
according to copyright law if the Impala
not died but well it's a news story
because people were trying to remake it
racially motivated
she's an ancestor of a slave yada yada
that's why times up I guess yeah I guess
just finished fussing with Star Wars is
that like I think there needs to be a
point where you mean that we are this
kind of ready in copyright law but it's
a little overly aggressive right now and
that it's life the author plus 75 years
but there needs be a point where
something becomes public culture and
arguably like if my kids are playing
with sticks in the backyard and they're
pretending their lightsabers it feels
weird knowing that Disney's like that's
mine that's mine it's not yours you
can't you just not yours mine I think
it's a prop you promise only I make
official lightsaber Disneyland they have
light sabers yeah but things like that
when things become hugely parts of
culture and like I said you know make
your profit off of it but a certain
point decades down the line when just
everybody it's just part of people's
lives and then it's not yours anymore
it's the people's and I think copyright
law if it's going to be aggressive in
protecting it needs to also be
aggressive in releasing it and letting
it truly be the cultures yeah yeah
definitely
I have one more point on this that I
want a question that I want to ask one
that we should do a video about the guy
who copy who tried to copyright the
English language because he invented all
the words what video saying conceivably
worth this territory it's like I'm gonna
make a language and they were in
speaking it's like haha you pay me a
nickel each time you use a word remember
the happy birthday song was copyrighted
for a while
yeah Warner Brothers tried to be dicks
didn't copyright them the Happy Birthday
song like that's a good example I think
that's a really good example of like I
mean that I shouldn't be somebody sold
the distilled version of what that is
about a video where a man copyright
wrote English spoken in English he likes
he's like going around trying to get it
filed and he's like look I need you to
file this and they're like well what do
you want me to stop talking don't say a
word
journalists would write stories about
that I do have one more question this
kind of taking on Clint's point here
which is about the little guy what
happens the little guy mmm
if these provisions are too strict yeah
against companies like Google and
Facebook the the my greatest fear is
that it would shut down them from
allowing people onto their platform yes
to begin with that is a fear if I do
yeah and that's that's a that's a really
difficult thing for them to deal with
right now because you you it's like
immigration in the United States it's
like country of immigrants all these
people came onto the platform they
started making things and then and then
all of a sudden it's like oh well how do
we rake do we need to regulate this you
know do we need to bail it like we need
what laws do we need and it's like huh
so can you shut the doors you know is
that like morally right is that like
right for the company is that right for
everyone on the platform it's not really
shutting games installing doors in
general right now
and now there's doors without locks on
them right but they're still using the
algorithms to like control what gets
seen - it's like there's still this
thing well anyone can upload anything
just like anyone you can say anything
you have freedom of speech but like like
you know ultimately the algorithm is
saying well I'm not gonna really you
know mmm that's why most people upload a
video gets like two views yeah yeah cuz
no one's watching it right because it's
just buried down there
Jim's never gonna recommend it - yeah it
does but I feel like it might be worth
jumping to some of these other hilarious
hey guys you have up here I feel like I
think article 13 guys we're just gonna
have to kind of let this one blow over
when do you want pick ones and we got we
got things like Everest bodies Jessi
Smollett which I feel like is an
open-and-shut case which it literally
was it was until until they blew it
we'll get into that in a later said I
lose something funny for hovercraft
moose hunt yes
Youngblood though yes yeah okay which
one what do you want young blood let's
go with young blood dude because like
the rapper it's not early teenager blood
here we go the US Food and Drug
Administration has made a request asking
people please just stop buying blood the
blood of young people for the purposes
of blood transfusion same data proving
health stop the announcement comes after
companies like ambrosia health no this
is a real company this guy created a
company called ambrosia health that
began selling leaders of young blood for
me to pay $8,000 a liter while housing
the blood would reverse aging wisely
save money
this one's jeeps like literal vampires
you might remember the Silicon Valley
episode where the guy that owns the
Google equivalent is has a blood bag
basically so he's on a living young man
yeah and they do they do regular blood
transpired by this because apparently
there was only there was a science
article about how scientists I forget
what the name of the processes a para by
OSIS it's where you stitch two animals
together make more parts of animals and
so there was a pair of iosys study done
with like basically an old animal and a
young animal yeah but they were like you
know they were incest they they were
they're bred inbred there's a union
video where they sewed a dog's head onto
another dog okay so this is what I mean
that's para by osis in like a really
[ __ ] up form but but so apparently
these these people did a study they
sewed two inbred mice together and the
older ones seem to have some sort of
health benefits from it but the younger
one which they don't talk about the
younger one also got way older wait I
when they cut them up or and when they
get them together did they stitch them
together like like this click on the
article and you can see how they stitch
like is it more humane to like stitch
the whole solution together side by side
side by sides I scroll down mainway it's
inhumane to do like a dog head on
another dog body maybe it's in the
YouTube video you want to do to half dog
half heads together so both dogs stay
alive apparently they system together
side by side okay okay this is so jacked
up right it's like jacked so apparently
somebody took this idea and ran with it
and they were like hey guys para bios's
some blood transfusion makes you younger
and so like the FDA had to issue an
official statement telling people like
hey you should probably stop having
people buy blood for the purposes of
trying to become younger I want to see
the doctor who
this I want to see what he looks like to
see if he fits every stereotype they are
only gonna show the people that did a
study on it he seemed probably seems
like it like a Nazi scientist kind of
type he's very very young and like a lot
in here it's got a big scar Stephanie
the snake oil salesman type just look
for it yeah there you go there's some
pair of iosys photos that's like
dragonflies wait hold on they go is that
a seahorse and a butterfly a bug stay
there with another bug and larva that
looks like so anyway they still yeah Oh
God okay so that yeah like there's a
mouse act that the fact that this is
happening is wacky wild and weird and it
feels like it's something that would
only happen in Silicon Valley but I mean
if there was a cure for aging would you
guys take it oh yeah I would thinks I
mean I think so like I'd have to think
about it exercise and eating your
vegetables yeah another life force that
was younger than yours right was known
as stem cells because the higher this is
vampire for every soul so in life you
regenerate your cells so like you're not
absorbing the life force of another lip
like thing unless you get your stem
cells from babies like blueprints out
there just for the record there are
clean a lot of people think stem cells
they think abortion they think wrong
yeah
stem cells there's actually a lot of
clean forms of stem cells that are out
there that existing it's very it's very
what's it called taboo in the United
States because of Allah we're very like
anti-abortion here but there is there is
healthy like morally correct ways that
stem cells are being done did you ever
hear about that uh that like stem cell
like spray gun that they would use for
people had burns and they could
basically a spray stem cells on like the
where the skin grafts would go in like
in like six days it'd be healed that's
crazy yeah there's some very expensive
ways it's out and working now okay so
the bowl forms and how
different house youngblood different
especially since it's like stem cells
are cells like we come any cell this is
like a bit like morally like like well
this doesn't do anything okay this is
actually there's a there's a married
couple at the University of Berkeley
that studied this and it's like
apparently very dangerous and it's not
doesn't do anything okay and it's like
essential oil secure cancer sticks oil
science basically so if if it did work
let's just say it didn't work yeah
what's wrong with it
nothing will your take you're making a
young person older doesn't know did work
so that does if it did work would you
use it maybe you'll try it out maybe I
was trying a live well that's tough
because it's like yeah like maybe what
I'm like super old my goal and well one
of my goals in life is to stretch every
day and be super healthy eat healthy and
live take other people's blood as a
medical care exactly it's a medical cure
in medical care for aging yeah right but
aging is in its problem killer of
everything it's guaranteed so I think
that because it that begs the question
like as what kind of person are you are
you person who would say give me the
anti-aging so I can live till I'm 200 or
forever if or not if your face was all
wrinkly and someone was like I'll sell
you the skin on my face for $20,000
would he purchase it I would I would
have to consider it but I don't think I
would I don't think I would because like
regardless your life is finite and if
and I feel like you're cheating yourself
by like making anti-aging I take a
little but what you do if I'm I'll take
a little book if you take a bike
who can turn this whole thing into a
convenient subscription service where
every Mart has that one leader of the
only blood and red apron yes where we
have real doctors that scan your body
and they they prove it at you yeah with
a younger body type that matches your
blood dump it back out there this
doesn't work once again just so we know
once a month you've got a bag and a
needle and there's no hassle and you can
send the blood back at any time now you
buy it
I don't know I thought they like tested
all her blood mice and rats
I thought they tested on mice and rats
and stuff that like you can try and look
at the articles I don't know but like
that yeah taking the blood from a
younger Mouse into the blood oven or
into into an older Mouse well they're
inbred mice so this is that this is this
one what this is different this is like
stitching two together I'm not talk
about that I'm talking about taking the
the younger blood of the young young
mice into an aging Mouse and you start
to see I don't think they ever did that
yeah I think also human beings are very
different than mice but that's of course
yeah of course
is basically like inbred mice lab rats
are almost genetically exactly the same
so what the people with the couple the
research couple said and this article
was that that also played a huge factor
in that study yes because they're so
genetically similar that like giving
them the same blood or stitching them
together or whatever they did was more
likely to be beneficial because of how
similar they were whereas humans
obviously we're not all inbred so that's
not gonna functions it so it needs to be
like son son parent kind of
relationships you make a spare kid old
disclaimer everything I say on this
podcast is a joke everything except the
facts yeah this doesn't sound any
different than like say a bone marrow
donation yeah basically it's basically
just like a plasma
and I get that I've you read back in
college it if it worked if it worked the
questions would you do it like morally
if it worked and I was really old and
like and you could use it as a way to
age gracefully I would probably use it
but I wouldn't use it to just like
[ __ ] live forever I think that's just
people that want to live forever I don't
know I don't trust those people hmm
maybe they're just really happy just
trying to find something to spend their
billions on I think it's a question of
do you
well how's life going for you and then
do you believe in an afterlife I think
those are two questions right so yeah me
being that life's going pretty good and
I do believe in an afterlife I'd
probably be like you know what I'm good
just like maybe like if I got in a bad
car accident and I would and I would
have died and I'm 70 and they'll keep me
alive for another a couple years and I
can like you know basically overcome
that incident in my life
that'd be like that but you would do it
do it probably yeah it would be really
funny if like you find they find out
that this works and it's like you
actually slowly get a little bit bigger
like immortal people when you're like
nine feet tall Trillian air he's nine
feet tall
he looks 20-person that looks like a
baby 80 and it's like the Year like 3000
yeah you know I tried to give blood back
in college and I said I couldn't ever
give blood because I happen to have been
in Europe when Mad Cow what's happening
mm-hmm and there's no way they forget
did they forget about that I have a
feeling that's like no longer a thing
like I probably could be a blood now but
they said that since I can't test you
for Mad Cow until after you're dead by
only doing yeah they had to do like
their to do a brain biopsy to see if you
have it no yeah so that like they can't
test you for it so if you're in Europe
for a certain amount of time
for a certain span of years you just
can't donate blood do they like pencil
that in like permanent records you're
probably fine I'm probably okay but now
we don't have mad cow maybe explain
something guys all right do you want
another goofy topic or do you want to
talk about Jesse small I want to say
about that let's all right what is keep
it short it's the same [ __ ] with article
13 which is every likes getting their
panties and a bunch of her stuff oh no
this is totally different this is way
different you know what's another set it
up first all right what's going down
Jesse small it was a guy that faked
getting beat up yeah so he was exactly
what happened by all accounts he was
inducted just give you the facts he was
indicted by a grand jury of his peers on
16 felony counts for failing for filing
a false police report what did he file
of Pulse a false police report about
that was the cause for the indictment it
was ace what appeared to be a staged
hate crime yes can actually reverse he
staged a hate crime against himself is
the way that the indictment goes and in
an effort to bolster his basically
limelight and his career yeah he faked
being the victim of a hate crime
basically he has indited as a gay hold
on to gay black men who face button die
against him for being gay and black how
do you get indicted by a grand jury like
what exactly what is that what is
indicted and what is that the grand
jury's an indictment I'll tell you what
it is it's this is the sixth amendment I
think could be the seventh regardless
indictment happens as follows police
pull you in for something they're like
we think you were the bad guy that did
something it's like well due process
requires that you have your day in court
so if the evidence stands it needs just
withstand a certain threshold so what an
what an what a grand jury indictment is
is they bring in like 12 people that are
like different age groups different all
across you know it's like people of your
peers it's like they bring in 12 people
who are like you're like you know people
that are similarly
you ate it okay okay and they say here's
some here's the can that we found at the
scene of the crime where that's got the
poison in it and you and you were there
and this is all we know at this time but
is this enough to pass the threshold of
like this is Vanda does it stand and we
have a case here we have a case so it's
not they're not saying you're guilty
yeah they're just saying given that
evidence and given this we vote that the
that there's a case here that's it we'll
look into it that's call them indictment
if that if that stands that's called an
indictment you were in a night and now
you're indicted and now prosecution has
a right to prosecute the case against
you so then you go to court so if an
indictment doesn't stand you're off
you're done you can go home yeah okay so
so that was indicted based on 16
accounts that means well any account
yeah
only 16 people or 16 different 16
different crimes 16 different felony
crimes a felony you can go to jail for 3
to 5 years one of these is faking like
basically they're all based upon this
fall this this incident basically they
presented this incident to that jury and
the jury was like yes we could conceive
that he but there's a case there's a
case for the 16 different criminal act
not prove it's not prove is not proven
right well I got a cursory glance this
even more ridiculous things taken to
this yeah the Chicago Mayor Rahm Emanuel
who if people want to say that this is
politically motivated I'll give you some
evidence ok Rahm Emanuel was President
Obama's chief of staff
he's a Blue Dog Democrat from Chicago
he's like one of the down homies from
the blue side he stood up with the
Chicago chief of police and they said
basically that this is a whitewash of
justice for people of notoriety and fame
to get treated one way while others get
treated another he said those words on
camera to the press very clearly saying
like we presented our detectives went
out got evidence on this case because
remember when this first happened when
chief did you leave out he detail here
he did say the crime was the whitewash
he says this
the twist is he was indicted and then
just recently all charges were dropped
in the case is sealed so no one will
ever get to look at the evidence yes he
is completely let go and he's yeah let
off not guilty so despite the 16 counts
though no trial none of that just Quebec
okay we're done God bye
it's over everyone go home and so what
nothing happened here has cleaned it up
yeah nothing happened yeah so something
happened along the way he paid $10,000
bond and surrendered that yes he paid
$10,000 bond surrendered his bond and as
a condition of giving up his bond they
sealed the case and sent him home no
something no something happened he's so
everybody's going out and saying like
this is just an example of rich people
getting treated differently and a famous
people getting treated differently and
while that certainly is true that rich
and famous people are treated
differently most likely because they can
hire a good lawyer team I think what
this speaks to because there's plenty of
also rich people that get in trouble
this speaks to the prosecution messing
something up and then as they were going
to court people going oh this is not
going to stand up well and you guys
gonna be super embarrassed in the city
of Chicago is gonna have egg on its face
the best bet you guys can do
pack it up don't let anybody look at it
and just walk away that's probably that
that could be what happened I don't
understand that that's probably what
happened but all I know is you had the
Chief of Police going out there and
basically saying this guy's guilty yeah
well but before before the evidence came
out that he may have done this against
himself when it first happened the chief
of police said I have no reason to
believe that he's being dishonest in any
way and then BOOM a couple days later
turns out oh maybe so it's not like the
chief of police immediately took a side
or something he was just like well we'll
see what happens here it sounds like
this guy's got a case and we need to
look into it and then they looked into
it they're like actually we think he did
it and then and then then the case got
shut down state prosecution was like
we're not moving forward to close the
case and then he's like and then and
then him and Rahm Emmanuel came out and
they were like pretty sure this happened
and can't believe that it's ending this
way
so who knows because it's not like Rahm
Emanuel doesn't talk to the state
prosecutor and if there is that egg on
the face evidence as you're saying that
would be a bad look why would he come
out so strongly and say that what it was
just a political maneuver I mean it's
worth mentioning I mean it's not may not
his fault so we could be saying like
this is definitely a miscarriage of
justice etc etc but I think at the end
of the day anything we say is just
assumption and like yeah it sucks that's
not going to court it should have gone
to court somebody screwed up but I think
to Amelia jump to the conclusion that's
like yeah some corruptions happening
he's getting paid off he's a rich guy
etc like I think that's just jumping to
your own internal narrative I don't
actually I don't I don't see that
headline though really either that
there's like some like rich guy
conspiracy thing going it's like it's
everyone is trying to get into safe face
or something no I I'm just saying like I
don't I don't actually think that's the
narrative that I've seen here I feel
like I've certainly seen a good amount
of that narrative but either way there's
a wild wild situate somebody effed up
big-time
see things gonna come back or do you
think it's no it's done it looks like
they're they're considering doing a
civil suit against them to redo that
coop all the money that they spent on
his investigation you don't know the
same thing happened in the OJ Simpson
trial he was not convicted of a crime
but not be convicted of murder yes I'm
not guilty of murder be the the
threshold for proving is less in civil
cases so non criminal cases the burden
is the highest you must prove beyond a
reasonable doubt but in civil cases
usually it's just by a preponderance of
the evidence which is just usually like
more than 50% loser so yeah so they
could say so the city could go after him
to say you did this but in civil court
rather than as a crime mm-hmm and so
that could still move forward he could
still owe large amounts of money to the
city if they went after him that way
yeah that's what that's what the OJ
system is the case is brought up because
he was found not guilty and then he was
basically yeah
wants to pay much money so he moved to
Florida where you can avoid a lot of
those payments
yeah if any armed some and then he
robbed somebody with a gun he actually
just got a jail I think for that so
funny but good times another funny story
is so he moved to Florida basically to
avoid paying the fines which is scummy
but he made that book that if I did it
book to make some money and Nicole
Browns Hanley's like hey wait a minute
we own this book because we own all of
you and all the money you make so
actually this is even paid us this book
is now ours and then they took the FI
part and made it really tiny on the
front page so just as I did it Oh Jay
Simpson I think they could change the
title but they could definitely change
the font size the family of Nicole Brown
who was murdered yeah they won the civil
suit cuz like he hasn't paid them the
money that they're owed Oh Jay yeah no
not just a small yeah so yeah I guess
there was and there was a lot of people
after the OJ case that they saw him and
hung out with him and you know had
first-hand communication with him
afterwards and the big thing that they
like seem to say it was this guy really
did it I wonder if the same thing is
gonna happen here where people he goes
back to you now and talk to him and they
go of course they of course they are I
mean I at least so surprised to see
Jesse smaller than any sort of like
acting thing from here on out it's it's
over it's done his career is done yeah
don't sweat it that he was an actor he
was take take a read with HBO and Howard
the HBO the music show at the music
annalee that owns the record company
okay well thank you do one more all
right
yeah you want to talk about a man
hunting a moose on a hovercraft
bodies on ever choice I read a great are
all about dead bodies and Everest
actually yeah did you do both Sam let us
do bull nine minutes all right all right
let's start with Everest yeah alright
guys apparently the treacherous journey
to the summit of Mount Everest is
riddled with dead bodies and melting
glaciers are revealing dozens of them
well nearly five thousand people has
successively climb the mountain 300 are
thought to have died along the way and
removing the bodies is a delicate
dangerous and extremely costly task in
addition to having legal constraints
including a nepali law requiring
government agencies to be involved in
dealing with the removal of the bodies
this body of mine so what kind of person
are you would use with the site of dead
bodies encourage you to keep climbing or
discourage you from trying to go further
na na pay respects pay these people died
on this mountain what if it's like gold
warning its I hate it you just passed 18
dead bodies oh where are you going
no yeah going up these people gave their
lives to climb this mountain I'm going
to the top I'm gonna keep what if what
have you just adding up like one of them
that's so be it so be it see your if you
climb Mount Eris you better be ready to
die exactly okay exactly this is not a
walk in the park I'll do Everest hey
what are you doing this weekend I never
believed the bodies leave the bodies
okay what's yeah what's the question
like here's the quicker I think here's
the question in at no many years is it
gonna take let me let me let me let me
go is a deeper question how many years
will it be before there are so many
bodies on Everest it's unclean
it's like a hit the bottom of that's
like you're an example you know and
you're trying to get like a secret
artifact and you go across this like
spiked pit trap but there's so many
bodies that are enjoyed and touch that
you can kind of walk across leave me
there well that's your right
it's your I parent Lee everyone like
goes up like you sign something or you
tell whoever whatever organization
you're part of its going else what you
want to happen to your body if you die
and you have to leave like an emergency
contact there's a fantastic sorry
fantastic news article on New York Times
actually on the website and I suggest
you read it on the website because the
way they've laid it out is great talking
about two doctors from India that died
on the mountain and India put forth this
big effort to actually get the bodies
down great yeah do it admits to like but
a lot of the controversy was like you're
risking the Sherpas lives you're you
know making a big fuss out of this etc
but it became important as kind of
publicity stunt for India to make this
happen and like show that they were
gonna get these bodies back but the
article is the Indians left behind the
articles incredibly well-written and the
crazy thing is
so there's GoPros and the guys heads
that did this climb and eventually died
so there's pictures all the way up and
you can see like the last moments when
like you know this is the last time we
saw them and then like and then we found
them outside and like this parts were
like they would hear them just like
screaming as they went crazy like out in
the snow because they would lose like
their oxygen and blood flow and then
yeah it's an incredible article I mean I
suggest everybody read it people could
hear them crazy yeah because you're in
you're in your tent on the peat like not
quite the people like the stop before
the peak and it's nighttime and the wind
is howling and you're like I can't go
out there and look for them its pitch
black on the side of Everest like hell
World War 1 business and we're
potentially my hollowing friend right
yeah it is so intense man yeah yeah
that's you used to have it in world
or one all the time as people would end
up in these shell holes in the middle of
no man's land and they'd be half injured
and it would take them sometimes days to
dashi
oh yeah that's crazy and really messed
up but yeah I mean I guess that's the
thing it's like if you can defeat that
mountain you know I think may about you
though if you like feel the need to do
that it's like the big thing that kills
people on Everest is that they a don't
know their limits be they aren't
following protocol and see it's
expensive and like half the time you
can't climb because of weather or some
other issue comes up and people like I
paid a hundred grand for this screw it
and that's what gets people killed if
you if you mix follow the rules and
you're careful like you have a good
chance of like they got off to a late
start take it to the peak so by the time
they're coming down it got dark and like
that's a big no-no like there's a
cut-off times like you do not go to the
peak from this camp pass this time and
they left past that time because they
were get going going late they're going
slow etc you know not physically getting
slow in that situation yeah you can't
get aggressive and you know they're
never gonna get another chance to get
back to this mountain and they had you
know dreamed of it for years and so they
went screw it let's do it you know what
I think it's a good good message from
this story is that rules aren't a human
construct you know I don't think it's
not it's not like just cuz rules aren't
just there to you know create civility
and peace but it's also for the sake of
like survival and safety and all this
stuff you don't eat that bury wait don't
humor aren't a human construct what do
you mean by the laws of gravity I'm just
saying like when I see someone cut me
off in the freeway or drive on the
shoulder to skip traffic they're like
rules don't exist you know and like I'm
like well I think about it and it's like
you know he means rules are a reason and
these hugh these guys and i like don't
go past this time they're like we're
gonna still go ass this time
it's like no it's like it's not like
rules aren't the nature like I'm just
saying like rules as a concept some a
lot of people like to think that they
don't exist or they're they they are
above them as like it's like a concept
but you start to get to these points in
these situations you're like no it's
like it's literal death as like the
consequence
here not just like a speeding ticket or
something or a fine or some an angry
look you know that becomes the
difference between malum prohibitum
or malliband say did you just cast a
spell on Sam
now malum prohibitum they talked about
this in True Grit but it's it's true in
law there's the concept called malum
prohibitum and malum and say malum
prohibitum means it's bad because it's
prohibited malum prohibitum or it's bad
because it's inherently bad malum and
say it's bad because it is bad mm-hmm
like don't go in that fire yeah hmm so
that's that's the that is the way that
law looks at rules effectively from like
the dawn of law mm-hmm sounds like Sam's
talking about some madman say you're
most certainly talking about that wait
one more Sam all right
freedom court on Tuesday ruled
unanimously that an Alaska man may use a
hovercraft while hunting moose on public
land hovercrafts are just balloon boats
apparently the National Park Service had
barred I had barred a man he was using
the craft aerial spaceship but what this
comes down to is jurisdiction because
it's it's not that the Supreme Court is
saying everyone can hunt moose on
hovercraft it was that the National Park
Service said hey you can't hunt moose on
that thing on our land and it turns out
that it wasn't their land they didn't
have the jurisdiction to say that that's
why there was a unanimous decision but
it makes a good headline too for people
to say like Supreme Court says you can
hunt moose with hovercraft so my
question is if you could hunt anything
on any motor craft with any weapon what
would it be
I'd hunt ants with one wheel in a
bazooka I would hunt robots on an ATV
with a pistol that's pretty sweet
what kind of pistol ggz probably beretta
no no okay Santa I would have I would
hunt
like psychotic like evil monkeys that
are like taking over and like in
investing some someplace with a
hang-glider
and one handheld nuclear bomb
I played the most dangerous game with
Theodore Roosevelt oh and a shotgun I
think you're gonna die although your
vehicle that's what he's wet what he's
been saying to me that's what I'm saying
to him we'll find out the vehicle
Oh jalopies just to spite him hey we'll
have the link to that New York Times
article in the description of this
episode if you guys wanna check it if
you want to like get a chill down your
spine it's a really good article all
right boys well once again thanks for
joining us here and consider hitting
that notification bell if you're
watching this on youtube I also noticed
some of you guys aren't subscribed as in
half of you that are watching this video
on subscribed so please consider
subscribing whether you're watching on
YouTube or just listening audio only
also if you're listening audio only
consider listening on cashbox
they're great all right that's it cool
sweet bye bye